off-handedly call merrell the goat and
we were doing a photo shoot and i you
know said something like goat and and
meryl kind of said that's right just
tell the old goat where to go
and i was like
meryl you know that goat means greatest
of all time right and she was like oh
no
because like with sex scenes you don't
know what to do you're like is it too
is it enough is it but the your worst
nightmare is is it too much yeah are
they gonna be like whoa
[Laughter]
you've been known to bust a move to
beyonce's single ladies
during partying while on set it's
actually a fiction that one particularly
is a fiction can i i would not dance
with that song i would never dance that
song okay
you're about to get yourself kicked out
of this interview if you say one thing
about baby describe the rest of your
life in five words
um
hopefully
not
too
short
too short
that's so poetic
we were all shooting each other with
guns but you are we're all in clothes we
were all good i'm naked we were telling
this story the other day and we were
saying like so there we were and she's
like huddled on the floor in her
bathroom naked and me nick and michael
step on me and i'm naked i'm weird on
loading on her
so you uh you played a movie called the
hunger games
isn't that your life story
you shouldn't say that that's
off-putting you should be off-putting
because you're fat
you shouldn't eat any more pudding yeah
yeah who are you sitting with at the
table weren't you
tilda swinton was at my table okay i
couldn't oh gosh every time she tried to
start a normal conversation with me i
would just keep going such a big fan
of yours and she's just like okay um so
are you miserable yet i'm like i'm just
really tired i'm such a big fan
and so it was just you and tilda swinton
at the table together well catherine
zeta-jones and michael douglas were
going to be at my table i thought they
started sitting down and i was like oh
my gosh and then they were like oh wrong
table and turned around and walked away
oh no exactly really that's like when a
waiter comes out with like amazing food
and you're starving and they make eye
contact with you and then just walk
right back
so they did not do you think they turned
around because you guys were there or do
you think it was just might have had
something to do with the drooling i
don't know
hello
what do i do
i what
wait sorry what what do i do i thought
they were gonna be questions oh good
come on ask questions this is so awkward
this is crazy time
x-men
what is this
playboy magazine
uh days of future past porn are you
looking at
he's like this reminds me of porn no i
didn't say that at all it's just what is
this
blue boobs in everyone's face and now i
gotta look out for the country it's
irresistible
we were like on a beach and then they
threw us a football and they're like
play football and all the other models
were like playing football like in a
pretty way you know like and not me
i was all of the photos i've got a red
face covered in sweat my nostrils are
flared
and like at one point a girl yelled just
get her away from me
most used app on your phone
um
oh god i hate the answer but tick-tock
oh okay yeah do you do the tick-tock
tick-tockers in here do do you do the
tick-tocks or do you no i don't make
tick tocks why not oh my god
can you imagine
people would watch i know
i was reading trashy magazines i was on
an airplane it's it's my one guilty
pleasure and i'm flipping through and i
find a picture of me in a bathing suit i
show this picture and it's not my butt
and i will not take responsibility for
it it's a 90 year old butt that's been
photoshopped onto my body and is posing
as my butt may i show this yes this is
not your name this is not my butt
you have proof you you have something by
which we could compare well no
yeah
i'm sure somewhere
show the 90 year old that just
everyone i don't know feast your eyes on
this
look at that
look at that
that's not you no
and my face looks like i know what
they're doing my face almost looks like
that's not my butt yeah even in the
photo do you know where this was taken
do you remember in hawaii when i was
surfing with my brother whoa you surf
really yeah well i mean not not well but
yeah
that's pretty cool put it down now
okay
god
want me to make a t-shirt of it
what did you do what was it would you
have fun what did you do for the last
three years i just have a ton of sex
[Laughter]
good for you
good for you
can you name five jennifer lawrence
movies five jennifer lawrence movies i
know who is that face
right jennifer aniston is way better
than jennifer lawrence do you agree
yeah much better i love her prettier
funnier yeah better movies yeah
overall yeah great um
i'm jennifer lawrence
i love that emergency lipstick i did
yeah you should hide it from the camera
yeah and if you guys don't know this is
where babies come from
no showbiz i'm so happy i picked this
dress
[Music]
is a registered nurse
is jennifer lawrence
quitting hollywood
i don't know if it'll be my choice
i think i'm more likely to be fired
was it the night you won your oscar the
night i won my oh i don't want to talk
about that night i had a whole meltdown
um
okay
series
i forgot to thank the director so i was
just like what does it all mean nothing
but but they didn't check the lower
intestine no we only had time for the
upper so i'm gonna i'm gonna like chill
for a few weeks and just kind of like
are you in pain now
no yeah
might be on my i might actually be crazy
no no no no no no
no no there's something here so is it
worse after you eat no yes it is which
is not like an ulcer it's not like i had
a fault i would find it hard to believe
that you would have an ulcer i think
that that i don't if you knew my stress
levels and the coffee intake you don't
have to really understand no i don't
have
have an ulcer i have some something's
wrong with me
and i'm going to find out what it is
i don't care how many medical bills i
rack up i'm going to get a disease
wait a minute wait a minute this is
running off the rails somebody's going
to have to just give me something so i'm
like okay that's what i have you know
the last time you and i saw each other
we were having an animated discussion
about whether or not a photograph was
you your butt or not your butt right and
now it's it's escalated to hear what
we're talking about i know god let's
talk about something normal how about
that mirror smokes crack
you don't google image
bacteria do you
bacteria yeah no rashes
adorable bacteria
it's called
it's called giardia is it all over our
seeds oh you have it on your phone okay
yeah
i've been i've been planning this for
days
we'll get one of those lights
he's so cute it looks like the uh
the kool-aid oh do you mind if i show
this to you oh it is
it is kind it does look like a pixar
type isn't he cute he's adorable yeah do
they all look like that or is it just
that one no no no staph apocalypse is a
mean looking bacteria oh you're not
kidding around with this stuff huh no
wow why did you look that one up
um giardia because i thought i had it
do you put this on other people too i
for instance will diagnose my wife and
always correctly and i'm just but you're
always correct always right that
happened to me i was bothering somebody
about a mole and i was like that mole is
bad news really yeah and the person was
like you think everything's bad news
because you're a psycho and i was like
yes but that's a bad mole and they
didn't even tell me when they went to
the doctor because i was so crazy
and the doctor said i saved their life
oh they're right
do you ever get so cold that you start
sweating is that just a gross no problem
i have no i
i didn't know it was possible for the
human anatomy to behave that way but it
is cold cold sweat have you have you
always been hypochondriacal
i don't know what that means but that
sounds like a disease which means i have
it
so yes
yes i am
oh thank you good lord what is that oh
thank you so much thanks pat oh my god
[Applause]
let me enter there
let me get in there
[Applause]
okay
good night everybody
get right under here
oh i wish they'd go away
i wish they'd go away don't you
they can't see us now
everybody